what up this is Matt Barnes make sure
you catch me on my homeboy bootleg Cavs
podcast
special guest in here the legendary Matt
Barnes welcome brother welcome welcome
thanks for having me NBA veteran
legendary podcaster NBA broadcaster
personality he's got hands the man of
many talents yo appreciate you pulling
up man for real for real thank you for
having me bro you're um always uh one of
my favorite players to watch bro when
you were playing because like I always
like look at the players who I'm like
man
that's I hate watching him but if he was
on my team I would love him
I just play hard I mean I was a football
player you know I mean I played football
growing up I kind of got into basketball
late Junior highest because I kept
getting taller and I started taking more
serious but I grew up being football so
I just looked at myself as like a
football player out there playing
basketball so I like the physicality I
played hard and you know it I got 15
years out of it so it was cool what
position did you play in football
receiver that makes sense that was nice
not the two-month horn I was nice though
I was the let the nation in touchdowns I
was All-American like the top receiver
coming out of high school where uh were
you actually like originally from
um so born in San Jose lived there for
about six seven years and then uh did
the rest of my time for like eight to 18
in Sacramento and then came down to La
for UCLA and pretty much been in La ever
since yeah so you are a west coast boy
for real for real Kelly yup yeah I mean
so obviously growing up you had to be a
Kings fan Chris Webber fan so I grew up
a Lakers fan Magic Johnson you know uh
showtime in the early 80s when I started
my dad like the Lakers so I grew up
literally liking them and the 49ers and
then uh the kings came you know when I
got the sack you know the kings were the
team but they weren't very good so I
started like I always have respect
because that's where I was you know kind
of growing up at but you always paid
attention yeah but yeah uh but once they
got Webb and and Jay will first and Bib
and those are the you know those are the
homies that's when I really kind of
started rooting for him so I remember
being at UCLA when that Kings lakershit
was going on that was a serious beef I
said it was fun in the early 2000s yeah
that's one of like I feel like when we
talk about like teams that like never
got a ring yeah oh yeah one of the
greatest to never win it I think it's
like the Kings and the Run and Gun Sons
like the seven seconds or less Sons uh
one of those Portland teams we're good
oh those Portland teams even even the
Pacers teams yeah those the the mouse at
the palace here those guys were supposed
to be the best team in the league yeah
it's crazy you were like uh you were
kind of like I feel like
we were just talking a bit off the
camera but you were kind of like the
veteran that I felt like the Young Dudes
really also respected on your team so
would that be fair to say you know I
just I led by example you know what I
mean like I played my ass off I'll do
anything for the team they know I'm team
first and and I treated them like my
family so whenever there was Smoke on
the court they knew I was gonna be in it
like all the majority of the times I got
fined like I find like I lost probably
uh they said something over like half a
million dollars in fines Jesus
um it was never me starting something
was me coming to the defense of a
teammate the only person that paid my
fives that man was cold but everyone
else let me take them shits I was [ __ ]
up because you defend somebody so yeah
man I mean like I said I mean that's
just like I said I I grew up with you
know a father that if your brother and
sister fight fight you better fight man
if they win or lose you better fight it
you're gonna get your ass for that so oh
you're gonna get your ass whooped so
that's kind of how I grew up so I just
always looked at my teammates's family
it's just like whenever it was not that
I'm the toughest baddest [ __ ]
but I'm always gonna have just know I'm
always gonna have your back
right or wrong I'm gonna have your back
so that's just kind of the the way I
played so you know when I spoke I was
never the star I was a role player but I
was never the starboard but you were
starting a lot of your career man but
every team I was on you know like I was
a respected voice like I wouldn't say
too much you know I pick and choose when
I spoke but it was a respected voice
began because I think that I just led by
example yeah it's great so when you had
Kobe's back and you gotta fined he paid
your fines you're the only dude that's
crazy you would think because I've been
watching like obviously this year there
was a um
the guy who I can't stand right now
because of how he's treated my sons is
Patrick Beverly because he he got at
your guy CP in the back and then earlier
this year he laid out eight now I like
Pat Ben though I just I don't like
everything he does and I don't have to
he says some pretty crazy [ __ ] too yeah
he sets him out he says him out landed
no it wasn't really to me it was to to
CP you know and and I'm just thinking
like I just didn't like I feel like
media
now is it's so it's less about you know
kind of covering what we're watching and
critiquing and it's more just about
being disrespectful exactly I just don't
like that you know I mean I feel like if
you know the game there's so much more
you can talk about than being just
straight disrespectful and it's tough
because we do have to critique
especially former players we have to
critique people we played with before of
course and that's part of the job but I
feel like you can critique without being
disrespectful yeah and I just think now
I mean that you see guys I Skip Bayless
he's tripping right now and you know
Stephen A Smith has his runs and I just
feel like guys like are so disrespectful
now that players coming in think they
kind of have to they have to like the
guys carry that type of energy but we
don't because we really lived it I mean
these dudes that are out here doing
whatever they do and I respect everyone
in their language the talking heads are
different than the former players oh man
we have a different we have a we have a
natural leg up right we really live this
you know what I mean so I just didn't
like the way and and the crazy part was
like when we had our little back and
forth
like this shit's all about ratings you
know I mean ESPN loves it he was on TV
like the next six six days yeah they put
him on and he has stuff to say like I
think he's gonna be good at it when he
gets done I just you know what like his
you know like come on man we don't need
that kind of you know the way he was
talking about Chris and then like I
think it's obvious there's like a
personal Vendetta there I mean we can go
back that's fine and it can be that's
right right right right though unless
you guys are really gonna fight and to
me that's and to me that's where someone
like who I I loved seeing Paul Pierce on
TV but sometimes anytime LeBron would
get brought up you would just be like
okay we get it bro like we get it like
you don't [ __ ] with LeBron it's the
first it's the personal stuff you know
what I mean and it's just naturally as
competitors that's just how we are but I
mean if you're gonna be on TV and and
really do what you know what would you
have the capability of doing you can't
be you can be biased in kind of like a
cool or a funny way but you can't be
biased in a hater way exactly you can't
be a hater you can't be a hater that's
some real [ __ ] because it's just you
know look at the old head hey like I I
just don't like
I mean this is a whole nother Direction
even going but like kind of like former
players that feel like they have to
disrespect the guys that are playing now
it happens a lot it just kind of respect
the evolution you know I mean I get the
money's crazy high and some of these
guys never gonna say man don't deserve
the money but you know some of these
guys get paid a ton of money and don't
put up the numbers that some of the
older dudes to get up Do by a long shot
and they're getting paid and and and you
know again I think it's one of those
situations where we have to critique
that's our job but I think you can you
know just leave the hate out like
there's just no room for you to me you
always want to love and push it
encourage the Next Generation to
continue to be greater and continuing to
raise the bar and if you're going to
critique somebody critique them from a
place of like if they see that they
might be able to take something from
that and yeah like constructive
criticism it's all about yeah being
constructed because otherwise you're
being a dick like really help these
young dudes out on and off the court I
feel like they can do you know I mean
especially some of these legends that
are that are on TV and I'm not saying
all you know all they do is disrespect
but there's times where I'm saying like
damn bro you used to play a player how
you gonna say some [ __ ] like that you
know what I mean but it's like you know
I think that the only guy who like
I'm not everyone looks the other way on
because guys like KD and there's been a
lot of people but I just feel like
Charles Barkley is in a space in his own
where Barclay can just just he just Shaq
might get some [ __ ] but Charles doesn't
give a [ __ ] what you think Charles don't
give a [ __ ] and I think and I love him
it's just a part of the culture now I
don't always agree with Charles but I
love the man [ __ ] this is me well I
think also Chuck's been doing that job
for like 20 25 years now so like he's
his NBA career has almost
his broadcasting career is almost as
great as some people only know him as
that's what I mean broadcaster you know
and but the one thing I love about him
is he's always been as a player he was
this way this is me yeah take it or
leave it yeah I mean so I always you
know respect Chuck but again he's one of
the you know people in the spaces where
when you know
I think someone like you do you give him
a pass because it's Chuck yeah I mean I
think he kind of did him and I feel yeah
kind of gets a passive people be on
Shaq's ass too but I mean a shack like
what can you really say to Shaq you know
what I mean so I think there's a few
guys that are just like
they gonna do what they're gonna do 100
it's not always hating but it's just you
know sometimes some some crazy [ __ ] come
out their mouth but I mean outside of
that I just think you know we should
always try to again critique but make it
contract because Joshua Peterson
something they can add to their life or
to their game yeah now you obviously had
a 15-year NBA career
um when you guys were playing how much
did you actually pay attention to the
Talking Heads to the sports talk shows
it was different you know I mean because
I think I came in the league in the
early 2000s yeah I mean so it was but
maybe like the last five or six years it
was so it got it was a part of that era
I think I've retired in 17. so the wave
it kind of already hit but now it's you
know it always continues to evolve but
you hear it you mean no matter what
anyone says you hear everything and I
remember getting a chance to interview
Kobe on our show and we asked him you
know because he was criticized so much I
was like you know what what criticism
hurt the most he said all of them he's
like I heard all of them yeah I mean so
and someone is locked in and focused on
what he's supposed to do like no matter
what a player says he hears at
everything yeah and they take it in I
think I think that's with anybody right
but see I used to be the opposite like I
used to be
the guy that would you know be on the
table getting stretched or getting
treatment before the game and looking on
Twitter for people talking [ __ ] to me
just to kind of motivate me more you
know what I mean like like use it as
kind of like a chip or like continue to
light the fire just you know to to to to
to to say [ __ ] you to to the haters but
it's a lot man you know and everyone
kind of handles it the way they handle
it but uh
the just it's a 24-hour news cycle they
always need news that's why I think the
quality of news has gone down because it
has so much of it it has for sure I
think I mean of course not even Just
Sports yeah in general and I think too
like you know this probably more than
anyone like I think the networks have
all figured out what generates ratings
is these debate shows
so as soon as you wake up you got Nick
right and then you got Skip and Shannon
and then you got Colin Cowherd and then
you got so it's like it's almost like
what CNN figured out 10 years prior is
like if we just have people on TV
arguing yeah no question it's going to
be a lot more better for the bottom line
than if we actually just have people
analyzing the game and showing
highlights it's all about raidens that's
all it's about it's about views eyeballs
ratings I'm curious because I saw you
you spoke about what skip tweeted uh
obviously Demar Hamlin is uh going
through it that was a very scary
situation as a pro athlete obviously you
know there's there's risk in football
you played football
um
but you know it was definitely a scary
situation
um and then the interaction between
Shannon and Skip on TV today was pretty
yeah it was it was hard to watch I just
it it it's disheartening because you
know as a as a player I used to really
like skip but I I thought his take
sometimes were you know would toe the
line but he was good like he knew what
he was talking about but I just feel
like I don't know I think as maybe as
his celebrity is growing he is his his
entitlement and his
lack of respect for players his co-host
has just kind of continued just to climb
and I felt though although he said some
other stuff in his tweets like
it was just an insensitive and an
untimely thing to
tweet out for the world to see at that
time when this man is literally his
heart is beating stop beating twice on
the field you know what I mean and
but skip is smart you know so when skip
said you know how can they think about
canceling or whatever exact words were
this is so meaningful but then at the
end he knows like yeah this is a little
spicy so let me put you know everything
seems so irrelevant right now though
like he knew what he was doing like you
just like again wrong time wrong place
for the Tweet but I think like I said
it's been building up like the way he
disrespects Shannon today this morning
wasn't on his model but like two weeks a
couple of weeks ago yeah a couple of
weeks ago it was bad it was bad and I I
made a post today talking about like
I've had and I'm not gonna give up no
names but I've had to put out two fires
of people currently in the NBA
they won the whoops Skip's ass
and I had to connect dots to to to get
you know these kind of phone calls
Hannah because like I said it's just
there again there's a line there's and
and to me he's and again he will you
know his he has a long line of you know
respectable work in this business but
again I just feel like of late it's been
crazy but it's just like people are
tired of that you know I mean like at
the end of these are men like you're
talking to men that that that raise
their children you know what I mean and
and have to you know walk around in
public with you just like blatantly
disrespect like motherfucker's not
playing that no more I think too like
when you know I think sometimes this
happens with Stephen A because like
obviously skip is the biggest
personality on that channel as as by the
way I tweeted this the other day I think
it was Christmas
and Stephen A Smith was on TV all
[ __ ] day
I was like this is the hardest work how
much money could ESPN be paying this guy
because you know he's he's he's he's
getting I'm I'm happy for steam no he's
killing him he's killing it and I
understand but but I'm from a standpoint
like I understand skip like skip has
that lane so it's almost like a one-up
type how can I keep how can I keep on
having my name in everyone's mouth and
being right you know what I mean so it's
just like but I just feel like
lately he's been in and you've seen
times where just like Shannon I mean I
got a lot of respect for Shannon sharp I
mean there's a lot of times where you
can see he's taking deep breaths and
then trying to calm down from having to
ring this dude's neck on on live TV and
you would and and you know there's times
where I really do feel like that they
have some genuine love for each other no
I yeah they definitely do Shannon had a
lot of because we had him on the show
not to cut you off but Shannon has a lot
like paid a lot of love and respect to
to skip making that show happen and how
skip City wouldn't work with no one so
there's a lot of love there like he's
openly said that but I think of late
like to me it's that that entitled
arrogance that he he he he throws out
there in in the one a few weeks ago when
he told Tony put his glasses back on I'm
just like yeah no that was [ __ ] crazy
you out of your mind yeah have you ever
seen a Rottweiler on a Chihuahua yeah
like nobody talks like you shouldn't
talk to anybody like that let alone
someone you have love oh man that like
that's that's that's your true feelings
you know what I mean that's supposed to
be your man right there and and to let
it happen on TV like it just to me it
that should a wreaks entitlement I
wonder how long that's gonna I always I
after I saw it today I was like this
can't last much longer I mean the same
thing I put the same thing out there I'm
just like you know unfortunately this
show I feel like is going to come to an
end because like there's only so much
Shannon's going to take you know what I
mean and Skip is who he is and they're
and it sucks because they're really good
they're great together really good show
it's they're better than Skip and
Stephen A no to me they're they're name
it name it because remember when
remember when it was Steven and Skip and
everybody was like what's gonna happen
Skip's leaving the fox I'll take Shannon
over and and skip over over the old
first take any day man I mean I I like I
like what Stephen A Smith does and you
know obviously I'm at ESPN so I got a
lot of love no no but but just just
straight if I'm talking like straight
like if I'm up them two right there
together they're Dynamic it's been gold
yeah you know for a while but like I
said I just I think he obviously Shannon
sees it the world sees it like skip is
just really really feeling himself on on
on a disrespectful tip of late and just
I just don't think people are going to
continue to to put up with that so now
you were a part of uh the jump which was
one of my favorite NBA shows of the I
mean probably since I've been an adult
because it reminds me of like
it just reminded me like when I was a
kid there was like dope NBA shows like
inside stuff and you know different
images it didn't feel like a generic NBA
show and um obviously uh you know you
guys brought uh Rachel over to Showtime
sports which is where you guys have your
podcast you had her on the show you guys
had her back what that going through
that situation and kind of seeing your
friend go through a situation in which
you know the cancel culture [ __ ] kind of
rears its head and their context gets
thrown out the window Nuance gets thrown
out the window yeah I mean it's it's
just unfortunate because you know you
you're in the business in the business
it's a dirty business you know what I
mean and when you kind of know when you
find out what happened it's just like oh
[ __ ] damn you know and then there's
proof of that's how it happened but it
still got played out a whole nother way
just like damn that's you know it's it's
a cold game but you know for any of you
guys go check out that Rachel Nichols
episode on uh all the smoke on Showtime
YouTube and it it'll just kind of show
you what have you guys cut a lot out too
okay am I wrong because it was kind of
short yeah no it was it was yeah it was
crazy because you know obviously you
know my thing is you know I'm also
employed by dealers you're on both sides
so it's not like I'm ever going to play
a corporate type role but if it's just
like I can't uh show that I'm like on
like hosting I can't let you just throw
certain people on yeah yeah because that
makes sense
reflection on me so I'm you know I'm
Gonna Keep it busy but I'm also gonna
keep it real and I had a lot of love for
Rachel you know what I mean man but you
know what's crazy was I had to talk to
some ESPN people after that and it
wasn't nothing like crazy
um it was just more you know kind of
give us a heads up but I felt like you
know if if Rachel's truth if her telling
her truth on my show was gonna cost me
my job there I would have took that
right because that's how to me how dope
she was how opening she was how how
important and instrumental she was to me
and stack in particular but guys like
T-Mac Paul all these people that she
really kind of just really showed us the
ropes on that on that jump show you know
what I mean so once I found out like
what really happened I was just like
damn this is this is sticky but at the
same time like I feel like I got to let
my sister talk and it was gonna cost me
money which was dope which was dope
because a lot of people wouldn't do that
yeah if it's gonna cost me my job it's
going to cost me my job but you know to
me her truth is important because she's
a good person you know I mean so we're
definitely happy to have her over at you
know uh Showtime now which is dope you
know we're continuing to build a
beautiful little ecosystem over there
with her Kevin Garnett Paul Pierce you
know myself that's great
you know we got guys coming in and out
so we got a T-Mac so we got AI we got a
lot of cool little like I said like if
if if
uh
companies play like pick up games with
like talent I like our [ __ ] would be
over like we got you guys got all these
Hall of Famers it would be crazy yeah if
you guys actually like yeah
let's go run up the inverse show I'm
gonna play on the showtime so ESPN you
know first Showtime or fox or whatever
it was so you know perco average Five
Points a game for ESPN I don't even know
if perk can get up and down the court
big fellow he you know I mean he just
tore his quad from slipping and
everything so he's he's getting healed
up but I don't know if perk got any any
points in him yeah what up we gotta stop
the interview real quick to tell you
about our family over at my bookie
that's right with lots going on in
basketball right now Lots going on in
the NFL playoffs are about to start
Super Bowl is coming up so much to
gamble on let's win some money go to my
bookie right now if you sign up for a
new account mybookie.ag
you can gamble from wherever you're at
yes go to my bookie and use the promo
code bootleg when you sign up for that
new account and they will match your
first deposit up to one thousand dollars
that's free money in your pocket uh that
you can gamble with so if you put a
thousand bucks in your account they're
gonna give you another thousand dollars
to gamble with so go to
mybookie.ag right now sign up with that
new account one more time they will
match your first deposit up to a
thousand dollars all right so like maybe
you want to put 200 bucks on the Cowboys
or some [ __ ] to win the Super Bowl
you're gonna lose that money because
[ __ ] the Cowboys but let's say you do
want to put some money on the Cowboys
you sign up you put 200 they give you
another 200. on top of that free money
to gamble with is called the double
deposit bonus and you can only get it by
using the promo code bootleg so go to my
bookie right now sign up for an account
let's get back to the interview yo let
me ask you this working with Paul Pierce
when it when he when he went live
because I was watching that [ __ ] when he
went live and it was the it was amazing
it was
it was amazing because I was like
because I remember like being like 21 22
DJing in Scottsdale Paul Pierce would
always be at the club having himself a
good time great guy like
but I remember all this great Energy
Great energy but I just remember seeing
that [ __ ] and being like this is the
this feels like if The Boondocks was on
right now they right they would somehow
parody Paul Pierce being that like being
at a house party with strippers oh
that's fun oh that's fun you know but
it's just like it takes us back
obviously
it doesn't get in the work Disney you
know what I mean like Disney is under
you know ESPN is on the Disney umbrella
so we always kind of have to be mindful
of that mindful of it you know what I
mean and although you know it was just I
think I just think it was just a lot at
once it was so yummy because I've had
conversations but I've renegotiated my
deal with ESPN talking about you know
I'm a cannabis Advocate I have a company
shout out to seven leaves thank you
shout out seven leaves sometimes I'm on
you know my Instagram smoking but I'm
also a coach or father all this kind of
[ __ ] I mean so I'm a bit it's a business
to me you know what I mean so I've had
to have those conversations but it was
just like Paul [ __ ] was just like a
perfect storm I guess of yeah a lot of
different things and unfortunately man
it it didn't end well it's crazy because
like back in the day when you were
playing obviously they would be testing
for weed right so like marijuana was
frowned upon in the league and what were
what were were you actively smoking yeah
man I smoked my whole sauce I started
smoking uh
I think eighth grade to ninth grade
summer
so that was your starting point you
smoked throughout the whole your whole
so what were ways you were dodging the
tests um so when I first got in the
league like they used to do one team
drug test in the preseason so they would
test everybody in one day
was what it was everyone knew to you
know stay clean for that test and then
you could you know [ __ ] had
blunts or joints in the car since we got
done with practice that's amazing
um but then it did you know it started
it went to four random so it was just
like a real job to stay so I would
always stay up like maybe every six to
eight months I would stock up on these I
would go to go to I can say it now
because it's not legal so I go to GNC
and I just tell them like yo they might
always recognize it like what's the best
uh drink to clean out you know the detox
stuff yeah yeah and they would be
upfront with them and it was never [ __ ]
that was out whatever we could see they
were here today no my cousin's on
probation used to always have to go and
get that [ __ ] and then drink a bunch of
it so it was always underneath the
counter so like my test day so I used to
uh pay my trainers
a little bit of bread it just kind of
give me a heads up like hey uh you know
because at first they would say the
names so we would really know who's
coming you know but later they just it
was when they were coming they wouldn't
say who was getting tested till you got
there so every time I got that morning
call which everyone would get the
morning card like hey drug test today
you know be ready uh name you get the
names you get here I had to prepare like
as if
um it was me so even though it wasn't me
every time I had to prepare and that
[ __ ] and stuff like you had to wake up
hella early drink this whole little
thing and it's nasty as [ __ ] and then
drink like three or four Waters and just
keep peeing like you had to pee like
three four or five times and then once
you pee that much like you're
you're [ __ ] is uh kind of uh
it's clear like you have a window of
like how long it's you know your pee is
clear like six to eight hours it's crazy
it's crazy because like I never thought
as a kid you'd see the day where like an
active NBA player like KD right it's
like involved in a marijuana company
that's what I said I you know like a lot
of people took a lot of chances you know
I got caught twice you get uh caught
three times you're suspended for five
games and everyone knows about it so I
got caught twice in my 15 years and but
also like you're allowed to admit
yourself to the program as well if you
know you're gonna fail one time I didn't
have my drink and they got me I was just
I was slipping so I I called the dudes
right there like yo I'm I'm about to get
tested and I know I'ma fail and they'll
allow you to come into the rehab program
and you got it think about all the money
the NBA took from people back then but
there's people in his careers on the
flip side they'll you know they'll shoot
us with Toradol they'll give us any kind
of painkiller we can ask for as much as
we need and I'm sure football's even
worse and it's just like they they want
to pump Us full of that but but not the
actual anti-inflammatories that aren't
addictive they want to find us
suspenders and some people lose their
career you know over something that that
can help us now that something is that's
legal now as well yeah because if you
think about the downside of any
painkiller it's
it's masking one thing and and causing
problems in another area you know what I
mean so it's just that temporary get you
back out there relief that that they
need to make money when you look at like
because we always hear that the I mean
you obviously played not too long ago uh
five years ago right well 2017 was your
last year was that the year you want to
ring with the Warriors right yeah
um
and we hear about you you kind of played
through
a whole era then then kind of you know I
feel like 2013 14 is when the NBA really
started to go heavily towards the three
um but who's somebody who gives you
like when you came into the league
energy like just someone who's tough
someone who's playing right now who
um
I just like guys to play hard because I
think obviously the game has changed so
much that like the game is continuing to
grow and it's because it's it's more
offensive you know what I mean like you
know 78 to 82. I mean the Thunder put up
150 last night against the Celtics I
mean these low defensive grinding games
they used to get don't sell you know
people when they want they they turn on
TV or they watch it on their phone they
want to see dunks they want to see
threes from Heaven can you imagine that
the Spurs and pistons were in the finals
in 2021 people would kill themselves it
wouldn't work so I say all that to say
there's like a it's kind of like the
guys that play like me are kind of like
a Last of a Dying Breed you know I mean
the three and d uh someone in four surge
tough you know glue guys uh you know
guys like Pat Bev guys like uh PJ Tucker
Oh PJ yeah um I mean [ __ ] we talk about
Jay Crowder Crowder you know Jay
Crowder's in a similar role like great
guy like great locker room guy great guy
OG vet
um so this the game kind of has has
changed so I mean but to me I'm not one
of those guys like oh man they don't
play defense no like I appreciate what
it is you know I mean like these [ __ ]
kids are so talented man these kids are
super skilled talented athletic as can
be and they're just you know they're
they're in their way they're taking the
games to the new level so I love it when
I always because I I'm I mean I grew up
a Jordan fan
um
I obviously was a Suns fan but I put my
I loved Jordan more than I love the sons
as a kid but um I am kind of on the
LeBron side of the goat convo I'm not
mad at that and that's just because I
look at who he played in the finals I I
feel like he went up against the
Warriors all those years he went up
against the dynasty of the Spurs
through Detroit he had to go through
Detroit who just won a ring to get to
the finals Austin
he had to go through Boston I think I
think we also got to think about like
you know
who he was who he had on that Cavaliers
team in o5 when when they went to the
Rosetto seven it was also was it 0705
when they went to the finals it was
against the Spurs but um you know I
think that like
he went went through the Thunder with
Katie Russ and James Harden I'm not mad
I to me I just think that the League's
talent pool is so much more higher than
it was when Jordan and of course Jordan
had to go through the Pistons and and
you know there was Larry Bird and Magic
Johnson and those guys but I just think
the talent pool like I I love watching
every team right now I have League Pass
there's not a team that I'm not
interested in because I got a couple
guys that can go yeah I'm like oh the
Pistons are on well Kate Cunningham's
out but I'm like oh I want to see Ivy I
want to see uh uh uh Bae like there's
like no I definitely get it and when I
was a kid like the Clippers like sucked
like they really sucked but even the
teams that aren't good are still fun to
watch and and have good right now it's
crazy it's crazy yeah
what was the question though no I was
going to say like do you feel like the
talent because you you played through so
many like 15 years do you feel like the
talent pool nowadays is just off the
charts deeper than it's ever been or is
that just recency bias because we're
watching basketball
um I think the
I think the skill level might be as high
as we've ever seen it uh Talent you know
you think back to the you know late 80s
early 90s and then I don't even want to
disrespect nowhere because every year I
had talent but yeah I'm thinking like
you know young Mike in that in that era
there there was there was a lot of
[ __ ] in that era but I think
often you know we just we're kind of
prisoners of of now and and what we've
seen of like you know I mean so
obviously there's a lot of Talent on on
on on both sides but I just feel like
the skill level the athleticism the
athleticism all this [ __ ] is just it's
it's it's it continues to grow I think
like back in the day like the Cavaliers
were like a big deal for the Bulls to go
against with Craig Elo and Brad Daughtry
Dougherty yeah or whatever the [ __ ] his
name was I used to play with him on NBA
Jam when I was a kid
um but I'm like no no like no like
nobody's gonna be like both of those
guys are all-time greats nobody's saying
I mean they were good at the time right
but I think now and I'm just like yo
like if you look at all three of the all
NBA teams every year it's like [ __ ] like
the fact like KD can get left off
because he was injured you know it's
just like the fact Damian Lillard is
like not in the top 10 right now I think
the game has just continued to evolve
yeah and it's crazy because Damian
Lillard's like an all-time great point
guard no question but back to my
original point like I don't any like to
me it's it's it's MJ and there's no odor
but in these three I can give with
Arguments for either of them MJ Kobe and
and Mike right as far as to me those are
the well you said MJ Kobe and Mike
LeBron excuse me MJ Cove and LeBron like
to me
I can see Jordan being one I could see
some people have code number one some
people have LeBron number one you know I
could see to me those three guys are
with all due respect everyone else at
the top of the pyramid
um you know you hear guys like you know
and you never want to disrespect Legends
or or people that come before you but I
just feel like some of those older older
players like when you talk about the top
75 of those older players that were
really like foundational for the league
and and and yeah like almost like their
meat the meaning to the league outweighs
their actual talent yeah I mean to me
like there's no way you can leave a
Dwight Howard or Vince Carter or Tracy
McGraw the Dwight things crazy for sure
he was the most he was the best center
for 10 years yeah so it's just like
there's so much stuff that you know to
me because like you said the talent
level is so much on a night to night
basis uh better than it was you know
back in the 50s 60s you know coming into
the 70s it's just like a lot of these
current guys that got left off you look
at it just like no those guys really
weren't better than these guys that
leftover was even close yo you had a
full circle moment winning a ring and
ending your career with the Warriors
obviously being a part of the uh we
believe run was
I mean
that [ __ ] I know you guys didn't get out
of the second round but getting out of
that first round against Dirk and the
Mavericks was so crazy yeah
um and that team was just so much fun to
watch but can you take me to that
Championship run I I know you know at
that point you were a veteran on the
team
um but what how how high was the
animosity between the Warriors and the
Cavaliers because I had Iman on and he
said it was he's like that [ __ ] was up
for real it was like the group chats
were active we were it just felt like it
was because it you know they they had
gone to battle several times you know
for it you know what I mean and then you
know Cleveland got one I think at the
twin Dolores had had two
um for the two or three maybe two the
one we want was the third the only one
one more so
um
it was intense you know for me
personally you know it was crazy because
so I leave I sign a uh you know uh three
year deal with Sacramento thinking that
all right you know just finished I'm
gonna go finish it and finish up at home
we got a new Arena maybe make the
playoffs and you know you know get ready
for my transition so I wasn't tripping
with us and uh so then the king's trade
DeMarcus Cousins at the at during the
All-Star break like while he's on the
podium making sure the Pelicans yeah he
gets told he gets traded so you know
we're to the point where they're trying
to go younger you know I I'm talking to
manager like I'm too old to try to
rebuild like you know help me out yeah
let me get up out of here you know I
mean and they were on the same Vibe so
got released from there but they still
had to pay me uh you know the rest of my
contract was guaranteed and then we're
really literally simultaneously when
that happened KD gets hurt for Golden
State when they're in DC hyper extends
his knee
so uh you know I get a call from their
team to you know Katie's down you know
we're gonna need you to come out I was
like [ __ ] easy call you know what I mean
not too far from home no you know so I
went out there
um you know the first night you know I
played like 20 25 minutes so it was dope
because it was just like I've never
played on a team that had so many stars
but it was just selfless like going to
work every day was dope the energy in
the weight room after the game
everything was just damn I see why you
[ __ ] be winning all this [ __ ]
like it's fun to be here you know like
Eagle this basketball no it's crazy no I
go out there playing I'm playing
anywhere you know 8 20 22 24 minutes a
game
in the very first game KD comes back is
about a week before the playoffs or
maybe I mean a week to 10 days before
the playoffs and the game he comes back
I sprained my ankle and nearly break it
the worst sprained in my [ __ ] career
and uh I was out I kept trying to come
back and I just I wasn't ready and by
the time I felt halfway decent I'm just
like damn I want to try because this is
you know we're heading to the finals
like it was a Western Conference Finals
like we're already eight now so as a vet
I knew I wasn't you know you know a role
player is not going to really be able to
jump in and you know if you're a star
coming back it's a different story so I
just kind of had to you know
stay in shape just in case they needed
me stay ready and then you know talk to
guys when I saw stuff you know I mean
even though I you know I was new there
those guys are getting that you know
they respected you know my body of work
and how hard I played so I wasn't
someone who was overstepping my bounds
but there'd be times where at any time
you know that's the thing cool thing
about it were out of that conversation
with Draymond had you know long
conversations with Clay you know I mean
Katie used to get down after games you
know burn a few and just talk about the
game you know what I mean so it was just
like that kind of OG
positivity and ways to look at things
and
and that team ended up winning
Championship you know what I mean but
yeah they had man handled the Cavaliers
that year that's for sure yeah no that
was even though those teams were cheat
codes you know I mean once Katie got
healthy and staff and clay and Trey and
Iggy and I just don't like like if Katie
would have just stayed on the Warriors
who knows how many more rings I mean it
would have been ugly I was so I was
actually very happy that he left because
I felt like the balance of power
readjusted in the league for a couple of
years it was more about Duos and not
trios anymore so it was like I like the
way it is now there's parody in the
Western Conference specifically there's
so much yeah there's just so much I just
mean like if you look at like the Suns
or the eight seed right now but they're
four and a half games behind the One
season I mean yeah you can make a five
game win seven game winning streak and
and you know jump up four spots or you
can go on a three or four game lose the
streak and slide down three or four
spots like the West is
super tight so let's go hey what UPS
bootleg cab here to stop the interview
and tell you about Bluetooth yes do you
have a dick does your husband have a
dick
maybe does your boyfriend got a dick
does your wife have a dick who knows
um
it could be harder I'll tell you that
yeah bluechill get your dick real hard
to kick off that new year you know what
I'm saying if you want your dick harder
than
Advanced trigonometry senior year high
school then go to bluetooth.com right
now use the promo code bootleg and get
one month supply for free that's right
free all you got to do is pay five
dollars in shipping
they're going to deliver the blue shoe
right to your [ __ ] door and discreet
packaging all right same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis
in a chewable form
very discreet packaging mailed to your
house you don't have to go to a doctor's
appointment in person with anybody you
don't have to worry about embarrassing
conversations with strangers about your
[ __ ] dick bro nobody wants to talk
about their dick with a stranger I take
that back I take that back
lots of people like to talk about their
dicks with strangers
if you're not that kind of guy or girl
or them all you gotta do is go to
Bluetooth right now and use the promo
code
bootleg and you're gonna get it sent
straight to your door that's right they
also got the new mint chewable that's
the same active ingredients as Levitra
so there's a lot of options to get your
dick right in the New Year it's 2023.
yeah your dick shouldn't be flaccid
after a like nice long stressful night
no your dick should be ready you don't
want to be a you know a victim of too
much stress too much anxiety and then
you look down and you can't stay hard
you imagine how [ __ ] embarrassing
that is you get yourself a nice lovely
[ __ ] young lady you bring her to the
place you're nervous she's a little
maybe she's a little out of your [ __ ]
league and you start thinking too much
and that dick's not gonna perform it's
not it's not going to perform how you'd
like it to but you know how it will
perform if you're on that [ __ ]
Bluetooth
you're gonna put in a [ __ ] Luka
donkic 61 Point [ __ ] performance on
that [ __ ] all right so go to
bluetooth.com right now use that promo
code bootleg let's get back to the
interview let me ask you this I've seen
because this year
it seems like there's like a rule right
where you really can't go back to back
to back MVP
that's barely ever happened I don't I
can't remember when it's happened unless
Larry Bird I got three
and I think there was a there was an
argument to be made that Harden could
have got it again there's an argument
maybe Giannis could have got it last
year the year before whatever A lot of
people are saying jokic
it's a bad [ __ ] man yeah man and
he's built like me so like right now we
have these two white dudes that are kind
of just like kind of like normally built
like flabby white dudes who are like
Killingly it's just kind of crazy like
yeah I I don't even you know I saw Bill
Simmons talking about jokic and he said
that he's
the funnest
player since Larry Bird some [ __ ] he
said some [ __ ] A lot of people are
pissed off about but like you do this
for a living you analyze the game like
how special is jokic and how special is
the now I know how special Luca is
because we should have drafted him over
DeAndre Hayden and I became sick to my
stomach every time
um but like how special are these two uh
White Caucasian unicorns in the league
right now it's [ __ ] crazy they're
incredible uh each I mean obviously
jokic first you know his ability to do
it all from his size you know his length
his basketball IQ uh I mean there's no
there's no holes in this game
I mean he's okay defensively yeah I mean
yeah in a league where defense doesn't
really matter there's no hope you know
what I mean so to me there's no real
holes
um in his offensive game and then Luca I
think Luca is going to go down as an
all-time great me too man I mean he's
only 23 years old the the numbers the
video game numbers in year four I'm like
if you go year four like one through
four I'm maybe wiltz can hang with him
they showed a comparison of him and
Lebron after like a certain amount of
games maybe a month ago uh at a certain
amount of games I don't even want to say
how many games I don't remember but Luca
was like two points better and two
couple rebounds better and assists
better than them you know through that
same span so uh and it's scary because
Luke is only 23. you know I mean we
literally just talk about this [ __ ] on
ESPN today like guys don't really kind
of hit their
he didn't even get in shape yet that's
what's crazy it's like imagine if he
wants to get away he's in Better he's in
Better shift than he was last year yeah
he's in better shape than he was so I
mean he's learning the game but it's
I don't think we've ever seen someone so
offensively
what's the word
brilliant I mean from the amazing passes
he makes to how he can score from every
single and he's a dog too and he's big
yeah he's bigger than him he's bigger
than me he got that [ __ ] attitude man
because he's seen it I mean he's at 13
Luca was playing basketball with
[ __ ] it was drinking beers and
smoking cigarettes at halftime you know
what I mean like Luke had been a pro
since he was in seven like for art like
my kids in eighth grade yeah like losing
been a pro since he was in seven you
know technically seven you know I just
saw I just saw a picture of him and
Russell Westbrook from like 2017. when
he was like a kid yeah yeah I mean he
he's been thrown in the fire so he was
built for the same I mean uh he was
built for this
um talk about growing up in Sacramento
Sacramento I feel like finally has had
like um a lot of dope big uh recognition
in the hip-hop world my guy mozzie um
free Mozzy
um but then you know growing up there
was like Brother Lynch Hung and sibo and
and
um listen to a lot of even though
they're not from like a lot of Master P
in high school yeah Sacramento is like
one of those cities that is like super
active it might surprise you it's a very
active place because when you fly in all
you see is like Fields so people like
this [ __ ] couch and then you
know the fans go crazy with their little
cowboy so there's a real misconception
that Zach's got a lot of smoke out there
it definitely does it's a lot of smoke
and it's not anything to brag about like
it's really dangerous yeah between like
Stockton and Sacramento it's a there's
bodies are bodies are dropping yeah dude
so it's just like it's it's um
you know Sacramento was different you
know luckily coming from you know the
Bay Area uh my parents were able to put
some you know money together to not
necessarily get us to get us in a better
area right you know like my cousins and
and like my aunt was killed in Oak Park
throat slashed left in the gutter like
my cousins that live in sack were in
like in in the heart of it happened to
your aunt [ __ ] yeah assistant
um I mean so I would always so my
parents you know were able to do better
by the time we were able to move
um up to SAC some they would always put
me in predominantly white schools and I
never understood why like never
understood I used to hate it because all
my neighborhood friends were mixed like
a Mexican blacks right some Asians some
white kids but I never got to go to
school with those kids so I always had
to go to different schools but
you know now getting older and finished
you know looking back I mean it's just
it made me the chameleon I am because I
could
hear me I was going to Oak Park and all
this thing I you know I grew up in Oak
Park YMCA you know Center and you know
so I could be there and then I could be
and you know the nicest part of
Sacramento with you know a bunch of
right white kids you know what I mean so
I saw it
so much diversity you know at a younger
age that it just you know allowed me to
kind of be able to move and and and
slide in different rooms now I feel like
you do you I feel like you do a great
job of that now I feel like just like
the vast like
uh diverse cast of people you guys
interview on your podcast is like yeah I
know it's been growing man it's been fun
you know what I mean I remember when you
guys did the Kobe interview that was one
of your first was it like one of the
first five or six it felt like it was
early number ten yeah 10 or 11. it was
one of the earlier ones um you obviously
played with Kobe what years were you
with Kobe I think 11
to 13 or 14. so that was obviously kind
of some rough Laker years well no so I
came right after they won the I came
when they were going for a 3p so Phil's
last year so you were there when okay
okay so you were there kind of like the
end of like the peak yeah yeah the Run
was over
um unfortunately so you played with
Lamar on that team yeah Lamar Lamar
Powell buying them uh what's the locker
room like with Matt Barnes and Lamar
Odom at the same time funny and run our
test was in that muffler and run our
test so like people don't know Coke talk
big [ __ ] like I was like I I right when
I went to team because I'm someone that
just keeps everybody loose Matt Barnes
Ron Artest Kobe Bryant and Lamar Odom in
the same locker room amazing it was fun
you know what I mean and and you know we
used to poke fun to everybody like there
nobody was safe you know and everybody
get fun poked at them you know I mean so
it was uh those Laker days were fun man
really fun yeah what was because I mean
Kobe is not going on anyone's podcast a
lot of people have podcasts Kobe didn't
do a lot of interviews so you guys
obviously had a friendship that stuck
with him and resonated with him that was
a very tough loss for the world
particularly L.A you know obviously you
know the world lost but for La for sure
they lost a superhero you know what I
mean like
La got to watch Kobe grow you know as a
17 year old boy come to L.A what was the
one thing that you feel like
people don't necessarily know about Kobe
that you know being around him as much
as you were cool as [ __ ] like he's not
like it was funny because he used to be
on the bus and talking [ __ ] back and
forth and he'd be talking [ __ ] talking
crazy and we everyone would be busting
up and I I remember one time thinking on
the bus like yo why don't you show the
rest of the world this this side of code
yeah
looked up he's like I can't show these
[ __ ] this you know what I mean
so cold the one thing like Coke was cold
like talk big [ __ ] was there anybody who
was too sensitive for his [ __ ] talking
on the team
um he used to go at pal pretty hard and
it wasn't the power sensitive but he
would just
that was just what I think his way of
pushing past buttons but he used to go
at pal I'd be like damn Coke
come on pal let's go get me go handle it
you know what I mean so but but cope was
one of those dudes was just he he would
run through a wall so he wants you to
play as absolutely as hard as you can
have no fear in your heart and go to war
with him yeah I feel like Kobe's the
kind of guy that's like not gonna ask
anybody of anything that he wouldn't do
himself and I think most great leaders
are like that it's like you know I ain't
gonna ask you to do nothing I'm not
gonna do when he talks you listen he
doesn't talk much he used to he used to
hiss when he wanted the ball
um when he started hissing you better
give him the ball or make it or he's
gonna you know I mean stare a [ __ ]
hole through your body but uh
do just work hard man his work ethic to
me was second to nine you uh were a part
of another iconic team in La Lob City
years of the Clippers was special those
are fun I remember when tiger redid Rack
City yeah that [ __ ] was we took that
late by storm it was dope because
obviously you know I'd come literally
come right from the Lakers you know what
I mean so to see and you were you were a
starter on that team for most of that
run I mean you were very important I
tell people like I won the championship
with golden state and play with rock
stars over there but there's nothing in
the world like being the Laker so when I
went down the hallway to become a
Clipper it was just you know a team that
historically had been just terrible
god-awful even though it's in the same
building same city terrible man they had
you know Rays of Hope every once in a
while with d miles and Q and them when
they first came in out brand
you know Sam Cassell and patino run they
look they had but Tim Thomas yeah that
Lob City team just
captured you know the NBA by storm you
know we won our first uh the Clippers
first ever division title we were
beating the brakes off the left by like
record numbers like we're beating the
Lakers by plus 30. oh no it was crazy it
was crazy and you guys were stacked I
mean we were D like the the my first
year
I think our starting lineup was CP
uh JJ karon Butler Blake and DJ and then
Off the Bench they had Eric Bledsoe
Jamal Crawford me Lamar Odom Jesus
Ronnie Terry off
and I'm I know I'm forgetting some
people like I don't even remember Lamar
Odom being back on the Clippers I don't
even remember that Grant Hill on that
team I remember Grant I remember Grant I
remember uh weird like sports
illustrator voted us the best bench so
they did like a big old spread on our
team and I'm like we used to give our
starters work in practice like for real
but no that team was OB city was crazy
help me understand as a Suns fan who has
to root for Chris Paul he said who has
to root for Christmas no I mean Chris
Paul is one of the greatest point guards
of all time and I was ecstatic when we
got him but that being said the last
couple of years have been like just the
absolute biggest disappointment of my
life of my life all forms of my life
personal
relationship family the sons so they
went to the finals they went to the
finals we're up 2-0 to the Bucks gave
that back gave that back real quick and
then they lost to Dallas and then we
lost we got destroyed we got absolutely
embarrassed by the Mavericks shortly
after Alvarado gave us some work in that
first round Series against uh the
Pelicans but
give me like the Chris Paul thing
because I have friends that are close to
the sun's team and you played with them
we always hear about him and Blake
didn't necessarily get along like what
do you think it is about CP that seems
to be it he because he goes to teams and
they get good right away I mean he took
that team uh the Thunder team that OKC
team that was crazy I think Chris is a
throwback point guard from a standpoint
and he's not going to tell you what you
want to hear he's going to tell you what
you need to hear and I think sometimes
his delivery is off but what he's saying
nine times out of ten is right
it's a delivery thing his delivery but
again he's one of them like you know not
it wouldn't even be so much cussing it
would just be like
he's talking Chris is a talker you know
what I mean so he's always going to kind
of tell he's a quarterback I think he's
always going to kind of tell you what he
wants what he sees what's he needs like
all that [ __ ] um and me being you know
I'm you know I was always older than him
but just from a era where you can you
know you could yell at me I'll have to
yell back at you I will but you know I'm
out here I'm with you bro
and I just think the disconnect
sometimes with CP and younger players is
just his delivery because young players
have been kind of so coddled in this new
era where you know you say something
wrong just some of these [ __ ]
that get you fired oh it's we are in the
middle of this cancel culture [ __ ] yeah
so it's just like you know these younger
players have been given so much so fast
and I say they're not talented they've
just been given a lot fast so it's just
like when someone who's kind of a
throwback personality like is barking at
you some [ __ ] don't like it and
Blake Griffin wasn't a fan
yeah I just yeah I I just think yeah I
can't say they weren't I mean when we
were on we were on I think I think you
guys are one of the Prime examples of
like people forget the injuries that
happened in your guys's playoff runs
people getting hurt like getting hurt
there was like just some timely injuries
that were just like again like it almost
like the basketball gods are like no
you're the Clippers go [ __ ] yourself
crazy so that I mean to me because there
was that year you guys beat the Spurs
two years yeah there's two there tell me
those two years where you know we were a
top two or three team in the NBA hands
down we just
couldn't get out of our own ways hey we
got to stop the interview real quick to
tell you about our family at hard Dean
that's right hard Dean Las Vegas the
craziest dispensary in the world the
number one dispensary in the United
States let alone in Las Vegas all right
maybe you're hitting Vegas with your
friends your girlfriends whatever maybe
it's a bachelor party whatever's going
on you're going to go watch the Raiders
suck [ __ ] whatever it is make sure you
pull up to Hardy in Las Vegas tell him I
sent you they got the craziest selection
of Premium cannabis I've ever seen in my
[ __ ] life the pre-rolls the
cartridges the Edibles the flower all
top notch all the best the bud tenders
are so friendly it smells great it
smells so good inside a Jardine
that they have their own Harding
signature scent candle
see I sniffed that and I just think of
Las Vegas and picking up some amazing
weed all right so go follow them right
now Harding underscore Las Vegas shoot
him a follow get all the details you
need you can get you some of this fly
ass Harding merch at hardinglasvegas.com
shout out to our family in Vegas I'm
excited too because coming up we're
going to be doing our very first podcast
from Jardin in Vegas with young gravy oh
yeah it's going down all right let's get
back to the interview yeah it's kind of
crazy man yeah yeah shout out to CP yeah
um
where do you want to take all the smoke
because you guys have done so much in
such a little amount of time I feel like
you guys have really
put a stake as just the premier
basketball podcast
you know I think you guys do it in my
opinion you guys are the best appreciate
that man thank you
um first and foremost continue to
inspire you know I mean I want people to
know that like we could tell our own
stories now you know similar to what
you're doing and how you're inspiring
people in your space like other people
have always told our stories and now the
fact that we can tell our stories and
articulate you know how we really feel
and what's going on instead of having to
hear from someone else you could hear
from us so first and foremost we want to
continue to do that but then just you
know create great content you know I
think that you know this the secret to
our our success is like that's really my
brother I mean so like we can talk real
[ __ ] to each other and say [ __ ] to each
other other people can't you know I mean
so we always keep it light and and
always joking on each other you know
when you come to all the smoke you know
when you get there we're most likely
smoking listening to music eating good
food taking shots you know I mean like
Kickbacks so we wanted just to create a
really cool environment when you come
[ __ ] with us
um that you just feel comfortable enough
to kind of let your guard down you know
what I mean so I think that's what we've
been able to create with all the smoke
or you know the people say all the time
like man I've never told nobody this and
you're like damn they feel comfortable
enough it kind of reminds me of like the
athlete version of like drink Champs
because people go in there like yo
Noriega is our guy we've known him for
20 years everyone's having fun like you
kind of let your guard down because
you're in a trusted yeah environment you
know you know you know they know we're
not trying to do we don't want to go
viral for the wrong reason you know I
mean like my whole goal is always just
to humanize our guests like we know why
Steph and KD and Kobe were great and
Shannon sharp and Snoop were great like
what are they like doing other [ __ ] how
did they become who they became so I
always just want to show people the
other side of you know some of your
favorite people and um you know we've
you know we we found lightning in a
bottle with this with this show you know
so I just you know I think just think
the evolution I just we just started
season four and I told our team like you
know we got to continue to elevate so we
just did our we did a live show in
December with Magic Johnson
um at um the Beverly Hills and shout out
to Beverly Hills so we did a live show
with a live audience so that'll be
dropping I think next week which is dope
but I just think
um live shows
um being on linear television as well as
YouTube getting on that real Showtime
platform and and and and really kind of
continuing to just
spread our wings man it's been fun like
you know Showtime big shout out to show
time in Malco it's kind of their
in-house production they just allowed me
to create a lot of other and do a lot of
other things outside of doing all the
smoke you know they've allowed me to
bring talent in creating shows uh
producing shows like I'm doing a bunch
of different things about that umbrella
so I think it's obviously very
beneficial for both of us so it's been
fun yeah do you feel like uh because you
have you have a documentary coming out
about your life right no so we did it
was just a short
um a thing called Revolution that just
dropped on Apple Amazon all those kind
of things it was just kind of a snippet
of you know life after basketball and
what I was kind of doing at the time I
was bored right when I retired because I
didn't really know what I wanted to do
next so we kind of just started filming
my activism and
uh you know my street activism you know
my cannabis activism fatherhood like
just what life was like as I was
transitioning
um from the NBA so should we started
shooting that like five years ago we
kind of just wrapped a bow on it and and
put it out so it was just kind of a
snippet of what's going on in my life
like on speak on the Cannabis activism
front because obviously man in this
country there's still a lot of people
who are incarcerated for yeah for some
first for weed you know what I'm saying
and uh you know obviously sometimes we
live in California and I think sometimes
we forget that not everywhere is like
here yeah there's still a serious amount
of states that you can't even get
medicinal weed in and it's you know it's
it's it's kind of [ __ ] up you know and
what what are you uh doing in that space
um
you know I have the Cannabis company
that I'm a part owner of uh suddenly
something in Sac
um and we just we have a big grow out
there so we distribute to you know
people pretty much all over California
with that
um I'm a part of uh Chris Webber's got
uh something called players only he's
got you know he's got a couple hundred
million in cannabis funding that he's
been doing some different plays with so
I'm doing some stuff over there
um you know but I really to be honest
with you I haven't done a ton lately
because I've been so busy doing media
like when I first came out of the NBA
like cannabis is everything my advocacy
you know flying out to New York and
talking to the mbpa and the NBA about
you know not testing these guys and like
I was really trying to let people know
like this plant can help and at the time
knowing who smoked and like you know if
the world ever knew that
knock on wood and he's announcing now
that you know Kevin Durant is you know
listen I've seen Medicaid and it was
just like they would lose their mind
I've blown down the biggest Phoenix Sun
of the last 20 years pause no 15. I
won't say who it is but yeah yeah Steve
Nash would be 20 or something yeah yeah
so it's just like you know everybody's
using so my advocacy was really heavy uh
on the social uh the social uh impact
side where you know we're trying to have
you know black and brown people have
more access to being live to to get
those licenses it became so corporate
and and unfortunately you know dominated
by white folks
um just like everyone else but you know
you know now the industry is it's just
so saturated now like it's super
saturated the weed game is so saturated
everyone has a [ __ ] strain yeah and a
lot of all the strands are recycled and
it's your just your [ __ ] is just white
labeled with some some other [ __ ] that's
put in a different bag it is kind of
crazy it feels like it does feel like um
the weed game is kind of because I'm
pretty involved a lot in the weed
industry as well and it you know there's
so many like if you go to dispensary
there's a lot of that wig that's in the
same like three or four bags you know
that and then I mean I remember like
I've always been carrying weed you know
not to just luckily I've been good but
before it was legal or I always I
because I'd always take when we travel
because you couldn't find good weed in
other cities I mean now you're you're
you go to you're fine you just find a
dispenser you're gonna find something
good something decent yeah so it's just
like it's it's out there so it's just it
it got saturated but you know me I just
stay in my Lane smoke my seven leaves
that's all I really need you are
somebody who obviously congratulations
you just got engaged to your lady which
is amazing
um you've always been somebody who's
been on the Forefront of
letting everybody know being a good
father is a good thing to show off
because I feel like you're you're a
great father man I appreciate that man
um but you also kind of had a era of
your personal life on TV yeah man which
you know I'm sure there's pluses and
there's gifts and curses of that but
like
is that something that was like because
you know we all we all think about the
Derek Fisher thing and all that we won't
get into that but like was that
something that you kind of went through
for this new relationship to kind of
kind of keep some well you you learn on
the Fly you know what I mean it's it's
uh you know reality TV
um
it was kind of new back then you know it
was very new you know there was there's
Flavor of Love and maybe one of the real
world and then yeah but you guys are the
first I feel like you guys were like the
first uh that lane like the Basketball
Wives you know franchise was was was new
and it was crazy because my ex-wife and
I at the time it you know just had twins
I just moved to Phoenix I was just that
first year like it was at 08
yeah yeah and
um I remember my girl starts asking me
like hey you know Shawnee Shaq's wife
you know she's gonna start the show and
it's going to be us you know raising our
families and stepping outside of your
shadows and doing charitable work I'm
just like nah we don't need that yeah
like we're rich we got you know we got
two baby we got two brand new babies you
know we just got to a new team let's
just let's just so we went back and
forth for months and that was just a no
no no and then they got Shaq on me and
Shaq kept pressure me pressure me and
pressured me and pressured me and
finally I just said [ __ ] it all right
let's do it and um you know the one
positive from it was it it opened the
door to you know this content space for
me during that time and just kind of
understanding seeing like okay this is
how this this [ __ ] is made but you know
it's not hard to make quality stuff and
I'd say that's not quality that's just
not my taste right but like I can really
get in this space and start creating so
it kind of opened my eyes to that
um back then but then it also crossed me
over somewhat to a different audience
for sure you know what I mean like that
basketball wise I get Sometimes women
the women will see me in the mall or
somewhere and like the other guy from
basketball wise aren't you I'd be like
yeah yeah you know what I mean so it's
just like it kind of is what it is but
again learning experience but just
realize at that point once we had opened
our
personal life up to the world that it
would never close again like we opened
that book and
you know my ex and I we went through
some [ __ ] and you know we ended up
divorcing and
2015 and you know 2016 it's finalized
and you know the fish [ __ ] happened and
then you know me and him made up and
you know now we're co-parenting but it
was it took a long time to get to that
point yeah I was gonna say I think for
anybody who's watching this who's gone
through like a breakup like what if you
man co-parenting and being mature about
it it took takes a while to get to that
point right man absolutely because
sometimes you know the kids are used you
know weaponized against you and
it's it's it's tough you know what I
mean but it's just I think at the end of
the day you know you have to realize
that it's it's bigger than the parents
after that you know if you guys would
decide to to really be a part it's
bigger than y'all and you know the kids
didn't actually be brought into this
situation so you gotta you know
and it's it's so common now
unfortunately it is related families or
or you know father this or mother this
home so
um learning to co-parent you know is has
taken a long time and you're always
learning to be honest with you but you
know the goal is to you know be on the
same page as much as you can with your
ex you know for the sake of the kids and
again it took us a long
time to get there
um you know but we're finally there and
I get to see you know the boys are 13
now when we split they were [ __ ] five
that's pretty crazy because I just
remember seeing your kids on TV and that
like the fact that they're that old now
is like [ __ ] yeah they just turned 14.
it doesn't feel like that was that long
ago mustaches talking about girls and
all kinds of [ __ ] like that I feel like
they were just babies what are they like
playing video games are they video games
basketball girls
um shoes do they do the anime thing a
lot of kids are in anime these days they
have their own podcast called the Barnes
boys check it out oh fire Z like that
[ __ ] is dope like like you help them out
with like production tips and so I
started everything and then I took it
over to the company that that produces
my stuff uh malca and we've turned it
into like we're about to actually start
season two so that's dope you got the
YouTube channel going yeah Barnes boys
yep bars Boys YouTube so it's uh dope so
they're into that they love basketball
now and then in video games so it's you
know and then I had a four year I have a
four-year-old uh who's coming down the
pipe who looks like he's six or seven
he's gonna be a big ass defensive end
that's why I have my fiance and then we
have
um her daughter that's 11 her son that's
10 and her son that's nine so we broke
Christmas is active oh [ __ ] every day is
[ __ ] active [ __ ] Christmas so we're
we're four to 14 and you know six kids
six kids in the house at once it's
turned up Animal House eating me out of
house and home hey we gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our family
at odd sucks that's right the most
comfortable socks in the [ __ ]
world go to oddsocksofficial.com right
now use that promo code bootleg and
you'll save 20 off Christmas time is it
coming and let me tell you something
their Black Friday sale if you're
watching this before Black Friday you
might be watching it after Black Friday
but if Black Friday hasn't came yet just
like Cyrus hasn't came yet it's been a
while he's on a drought guess what
oddsoxofficial.com promo code bootleg 20
off plus whatever the [ __ ] else is going
on with their Black Friday sale and let
me tell you they got some new licenses
we got to talk about boys
my particular favorites
one of the greatest shows of all time
they got the Beavis and butt heads you
know what I mean and this is really a
big deal
The Big Lebowski that's right the
greatest movie to ever exist
and shout out to all you rappers and
people who be pouring your lean into
this [ __ ] some Mountain Dew Baja
Blast socks
Casino great [ __ ] movie you know what
I mean these are pretty fly Bubblicious
yeah that's right a little Bubblicious
and this is the big one
big deal here
we got Coca-Cola socks baby that's right
Coke's on board
Coke is on board yeah I mean we get to
put the coke hat on
this hat doesn't work for me does it
doesn't work for me anyway you could get
you this hat though hey Cyrus take a
Coke hat there you go go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg right now save 20 off and go
purge their website for Black Friday get
gifts for your family your [ __ ]
family will love you if you buy them the
most comfortable socks in the world it's
that simple or you could buy them some
[ __ ] [ __ ] socks you could go buy
him some garbage ass [ __ ] ethica or
some [ __ ] ass [ __ ] Nike socks
[ __ ] them get Odd Socks let's get back
to the interview oh my goodness yo there
was uh one of the more iconic moments uh
that we always see when there's Kobe
highlights is when you're on the magic
and you pump fake them with the ball and
he does not flinch
um talk talk to me about that game in
that moment and what led up to that and
just kind of because he didn't Flinch at
all and that was kind of you know like
you're you're naturally flinched I don't
care how tough you are you Flinch yeah
everybody flinches in that moment
um first of all I didn't realize how
close it was to his face
um but I just thought what I've always
thought he's a cold [ __ ] like I
like so I met Kobe in 98 so he came to
the Lakers in 96 I got to UCLA in 98 and
he was young and and so you know well
documented he's kind of an outcast on
that team when he was younger so he used
to be on our campus all the time like
eating chilling talking to people
working out playing picking up so I you
know I've known Kobe on just uh what's
up level since I was 18 years old you
know and once I got in the league it was
just always I knew when I was at UCLA
used to sneak back into poly and work
out I'm just like yo this motherfucker's
gonna be him I remember one time when he
had a broken right hand he would do a
whole work I left-handed the whole thing
like he was a left it was incredible
so you know got a chance to play with
them they were just always mutual
respect you know I mean he plays hard I
play hard
so we get to that situation with the
magic and Lakers they had just played in
the finals the year before yep
um so that following year was like March
getting close to the playoffs and you
know we were both both sides are looking
good so I'm thinking like Hey we're
gonna play these [ __ ] and
finals
um so which is a back and forth game and
and and you know guys that played
against Kobe will tell you like not only
is he a killer but he's like he tries to
mentally
bully you and intimidate you too so he
does all the snake [ __ ] with the elbows
and yeah for sure
L me and my sternum and knocked the wind
out of me that game like I caught a lot
like he tried to he was guarding me and
he tried to block the white shot from
help side and it came off the rim
perfect and I caught a dunk tip and as I
was coming off the room this
[ __ ] hell with me from like my
my groin area to my chest and right
underneath my chin and the rest right
there I'm like you [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] you're not gonna call
nothing huh like so I just got to the
point where
I was gonna fight him and it was dope we
talked about it on my podcast
he wasn't budging I wasn't budget
um but long story short we ended up
beating him that game
um they go to the finals beat boss and
we lose to Boston in the Eastern Finals
Lakers beat Boston in the finals
and then are you on the Lakers the next
year I'm a free agent the next that
summer and
um the the [ __ ] with Orlando fell
through so I was actually
um in toss of Pat Riley to to go to the
Heat and he's kind of telling me what's
coming to the Heat and that's when Braun
and Chris Bosh and like that's what he
was telling me who are the crunch time
lineup would be and you know he said it
would be you know me uh Mike Miller
d-way Braun and Bosch
yeah all of us are six eight all of us
do everything that could and then out of
the blue I get a call on my phone for my
number I don't have saved and I really
don't answer my phone anyway for some
reason I just answered it and it was
cold
yeah hello yeah what's going on it's
cold I'm like yeah [ __ ] like who is
this yeah I got your number for salsa I
was like oh okay let's see what's
happening
what you gonna do next year I don't know
what you talking about he's like you
know we just start going back and forth
and just like any anybody crazy enough
to [ __ ] with me is crazy enough to play
with me do you want to be a Laker I'm
like hell [ __ ] yeah so uh like
three or four days after that I was a
Laker do you ever think back to like
what would have happened if you would
have went to the heat oh man I would
have won two champs maybe three maybe
three maybe you would have been the
difference against the Mavericks oh yeah
because yeah I was someone who didn't
you know put some miles on dirt
um man yeah never know yeah I mean it's
always but to me it's you know to get a
chance to play like I grew up a Laker
fan yeah of course now help me out here
so you go to the Lakers is this around
the time Dwight and Steve Nash go this
is I'm at the Clippers by then okay okay
that makes sense yeah okay okay they
come there yeah and you know that
unfortunately that situation didn't work
out for them you played with Dwight and
I feel like like you were saying earlier
I feel like Dwight somehow does not get
a fair shake when we think about the
best play with oh man because when he
was with the magic like we're talking
about like all NBA leading voters in the
All-Star game
like they went to the finals finals like
Dwight beat LeBron in the finals yeah
the Easter finals Dwight in the Eastern
finals that's what I meant yeah some of
the most disrespect
ever from someone who was a factor on a
Lakers championship team a few years ago
like a couple years ago like yeah yeah
it was incredible what happened with why
does he just rush back from his back
surgery you know I mean he the something
was supposed to take a year I think he
was back moving around in you know four
or five months and he wanted you know to
prove himself was so bad to the Laker
fans and he was never the same you know
the the white I used to play to play for
I never felt more comfortable playing
defense than I knew when Dwight I was
behind me because he was someone that
would lay you out or he can jump to the
top of the backboard and block a shot
yeah Dwight was a beast man and he was
just so [ __ ] strong too so yeah the
white was a monster uh you're obviously
a big hip-hop guy give me your top five
favorite albums of all time I don't I
won't go um let me go people okay give
me your top five
because you got Tupac on your hand yeah
I got Tupac and Nipsey on my head I'm
gonna take Tupac and and and Biggie out
of it okay that's fair for me those are
my two all-time favorites outside of
that and that's and anybody can say
those two who do I listen to the most I
listen to Jay-Z
I listen to to Wayne
I listen to Drake
I listen to Nipsey
it was my fifth gonna be
it's probably gonna be a tie between
like Rick Ross and Snoop that's fair
that's fair yeah that's not a bad five
you [ __ ] with any of the younger [ __ ]
because obviously there's
um my kids like I like little baby right
I saw that there was a little there let
me ask you because you're a hip-hop head
there was a debate obviously I know
where I stand but they said uh the
little Wayne a little baby thing it's
Lil Wayne I don't even think it's close
it's not even close it's like like let's
relax it's like everybody needs to relax
with all due respect with all due
respect I love little baby and I love my
turn it's a great album everyone needs
to [ __ ] relax hey Weezy like listen
come on everyone needs to [ __ ] relax
I saw that tweet going viral I'm like
guys everyone needs to [ __ ] relax for
a second I didn't even comment on it
just because I knew that and I'm very
proud and I'm very critical of little
Wayne yeah everyone needs to [ __ ]
relax they're not in the same [ __ ]
conversation
yeah people these Twitter people are
[ __ ] insane man I'll just be staying
in my like I said if I hear it out and
about or you know in the in the content
space out here that my kids will tell me
about it but most of the time I'll be
staying on my own you know I mean the
the people I listed I'd be kind of
saying to them like heavy on the huge
just huge fan of nip got a chance to
meet nip when um
man when I first came to Lakers I was in
2000 and my brothers always put me on
music was like uh E40 always at these
Warriors games or was this something
that okay okay you know he was loyal I
love 40. that's my guy he was loyal to
the soil I just want to make sure he's
keeping that energy because him and I
argue all the [ __ ] time about sports
he's always from he was always front row
40. even that's the one thing about the
bay not the change subject that was
always dope was the Bae always show love
like the like that we believe team we
made history but they had been booed but
they always the fans were always crazy
it always smell like weed in Oracle like
the bay was the best that was such a
crazy uh just it was what was it you
Michael Petrus Baron Davis hey Rich
Stephen Jackson Al Harrington Monte
Ellis beadrants Beatrix that big tall
German from Lafayette he's from one of
those [ __ ] yeah
could drink his ass off boy they used to
call him Goose because he would in the
club with the whole
thing of goose when did you leave the
Warriors
um eight nine 2008 2009 I was there 2006
seven Monte Ellis was coming off the
bench on that team when you
say Monte was the most improved player
that year I think in the NBA but he
rotated from he went back and forth from
starting coming off the bench I started
off he was a bucket man oh man my head
was a killer he was a bucket he was just
a baby but yeah my tape was nice Melissa
man
um I love the podcast I love everything
you're doing I love watching you on TV
you do a great job I feel like
like we were talking about earlier man
sometimes you'll see like people who are
on TV and they got they got there
because
you know just because you're the biggest
name don't mean you're great at talking
about [ __ ] on TV let's just say that I
think we've realized that it's safe yeah
that's safe to say but it's dope to see
you know I feel like you've done a great
job of uh turning uh turning your second
career into something that's that's on
high integrity and um I just I mean to
me and I'm always me like JT said that
one time and to me it resonates so much
like every room I'm rocking on me yep
you know whether I'm at ESPN I can't
cuss as much as I normally cuss I'm
still gonna be me you know I mean I'm in
every room I walk in I'm walking into
NBC doing the king [ __ ] I'm walking into
Showtime doing all the smoke I'm doing
stuff with ESPN I've done stuff with Fox
like I'm just always me and I think
that's kind of allowed me to first of
all dispel any kind of Notions you may
have had about me like oh yeah it is
he's a thug just competitor and I like
to fight I don't like to fight them when
I'm over but that's just who I was as a
player you know but as a as a man as a
father as a business owner as a as a
mind
no I'd like to say I kind of got it
together so it's just we got to smoke
out Stephen A
yeah now he owes me a smoke out actually
and I feel like Richard Jefferson could
use some [ __ ] weed because he's a
he's he seems a little uptight loosen
them up
that's RJ smoke I'm ass I don't know you
should find out
shout out to RJ U of A even though I I
[ __ ] with ASU over U of A but yeah man
who hey who oh 809 on the sons that was
Steve Nash was that Robin was that Robin
Lopez Robin Lopez Grant Hill Raja Bell
that was the first year Shaq was on the
team right what we traded from I think
so yeah
Raja Bell was a dog too because I was
tough yep uh Marty Stoudemire so that's
the year Mario Stoudemire to go almost
got his eye poked out in the pool
remember and didn't really play like
half we had Terry Porter Terry Porter
was a new coach Harry Potter oh I didn't
even get fired at All-Star break I
remember that you got fired after like
not even happened I remember that
Terry Porter was a terrible coach it was
all bad you know what okay you did you
play with Earl Watson UCLA okay he
coached our sons for a little bit right
A lot of people feel like he got a bad
shake what do you think he did I liked
it and and the players resonated with
him too because I feel like they fired
him like super quick and like dude he
inherited a [ __ ] show with Eric Bledsoe
didn't even want to [ __ ] be there
that Ryan McDonough was trash and
yeah it was uh it was under some racial
tension that had went down with Sarver
that's how he got fired did you catch
any of the racial tension [ __ ] because
you you played for Donald Sterling right
yeah that was I was on that team you
were on that team playing The Warriors
in the playoffs and that was crazy crazy
um Chris Paul's been on two of those
teams now yeah
um but when you played for the Suns for
that short stint did you notice any of
that type of like work environment or
any of the no because I wasn't you know
I mean I wasn't really mixing with him
you know what I mean like you know I
obviously on the guys on the team he's
gonna be cool with the round he's going
to be cool he's always he's trying to be
cool you know so I never really saw no
smoke I had just had a little bit of
smoke with him once I left and he took
some slow [ __ ] to me during the game
I told my slap the [ __ ] out of him and
he told him I mean I got fined what was
it like playing with Steve though this
is sharp mind uh hard worker
um
tough tough yeah Nash was a beast I just
think that he he just wasn't the right
fit you know I hope I think Steve can be
a good coach in this league I just don't
think that was the right the Nets fit
was right for him but I mean Steve is a
bright mind and yeah I feel like the
Nets thing is like you kind of
you kind of don't want to be a fellow
Hall of Famer coaching the other Hall of
Famers if that makes I don't know but
yeah we'll see man would you ever get
into coaching nah takes up too much time
yeah you probably make more money doing
your thing anyway got a lot of respect I
coached my kids hey you team but that
[ __ ] that's too time consuming I just
don't have time there it is bro well
listen uh all the smoke uh new episodes
is it how often do you guys drop it
weekly every Thursday every Thursday uh
catch you on ESPN if you pull into a
dispensary and you see seven leaves buy
an eighth yes uh anything else coming
no right now I'm just Barnes boys
podcast your sons check out Barnes boys
podcast continuing season two be out
soon
um that's it man boom there it is man
Matt Barnes I appreciate your time
brother yes sir for having me boom yeah